[Music]
you ever been in this room before
no do you feel like you have
why would i
i know
you feel out of place
like your life isn't your own
you don't know me
this is all of the evidence seized last
thursday night we believe this is the
man that murdered harold slade and shane
fisher you knew one of his victims if
there's a link we'll find it tell me
what am i missing there's no pattern
it's just
chaos you can prove it tell yourself
think harold slade i know that that name
means something to me remember
that was chip before why did you start
at the beginning
you seem to have a distorted
relationship with time my perception of
time is better than anyone's
he's playing a game with us
so playback
lucy this guy's the serial killer i need
this to end
it's all connected your dreams your
memories
everything that happens
everything that doesn't everything that
will
and in this delusion of yours are you a
time traveler or a fortune teller
neither
am boss
[Music]
[Music]
you